uh I have a negative balance every month
and I'm kind of trying to figure out how
to how to get positive again um starting
off kind of a little rough every single
month after bills and everything so your
your bank account is negative every
month like you're overdrawn yep I'm
overdrawn actually almost on a weekly
basis and at the end of the day it's
probably boiling down to budgeting
issues do you have a
budget um I've been working on trying to
do one I Rec got the every dollar app uh
premium uh because it was able to track
my stuff better but yeah I'm I'm
struggling like weekly with groceries
it's it's just with a family of five
it's hard to keep it under a certain
amount okay so I want you to not try to
do the budget I want you to actually do
it I want you to go in there put the
numbers in there that's step one